I think it's pretty common knowledge how
to find the area of the triangle if we
know the length of its base and its
height so for example if that's my
triangle and this length right here this
base is of length B and the height right
here is of length H it's pretty common
knowledge that the area of this triangle
is going to be equal to 1/2 times the
base times the height so for example if
the base was equal to 5 if this was
equal to 5 and the height was equal to 6
then our area would be 1/2 times 5 times
6 which is 1/2 times 30 which is equal
to 15 now what is less well known is how
to figure out the area of a triangle
when you're only given the size of the
triangle when you aren't given the
height so for example how do you figure
out a triangle where I just give you the
lengths of the sides let's say that side
a side B and side C a B and C are the
lengths of these sides how do you figure
that out and to do that we're going to
apply something called Heron's formula
herons Heron's formula and I'm not going
to prove it in this video I'm going to
prove it in a future video and really to
prove it you already probably have the
tools necessary it's really just the
Pythagorean theorem and a lot of hairy
algebra but I'm just going to show you
the formula now and how to apply it and
then you'll hopefully appreciate that
it's pretty simple and pretty easy to
remember and it can be a nice trick too
to impress people with so Heron's
formula says first figure out first
figure out this third variable s which
is essentially the perimeter of this
triangle divided by 2 a plus B plus C
divided by 2 then once you figure out s
the area of your triangle of this
triangle right there your area is going
to be equal to the square root of s this
variable s right here you just
calculated times s minus a times s minus
B times s minus C s minus C that's
Heron's formula right there this komban
let me square it off for you so that
right there is herons format if that
looks a little bit daunting it is a
little bit more daunting clearly than
just 1/2 times base times height let's
do it with an actual example or two and
actually see that it's actually not so
bad so let's say I have a triangle
I'll leave the formula up there so let's
say I have a triangle that has sides of
length 9 11 and 16 so let's apply
Heron's formula s in this situation is
going to be the perimeter divided by 2
so 9 plus 11 plus 16 divided by 2 which
is equal to 9 plus 11 is 20 plus 16 is
36 divided by 2 is 18 and then the area
the area by Heron's formula is going to
be equal to the square root the square
root of s 18 times s minus a s minus 9
18 minus 9 18 minus 9 times 18 minus 11
times 18 minus 16 18 minus 16 and then
this becomes this is equal to the square
root of 18 times 9 times 7 times 2 which
is equal to let's see 2 times 18 is 36
so I'll just rearrange it a bit this is
equal to the square root of 36 times 9
times 7 which is equal to which is equal
to this is equal to the square root of
36 times the square root of 9 times the
square root of 7 the square root of 36
is just this is just 6 this is just 3 I
mean you don't deal with the negative
square roots because you can have
negative side lengths and so this is
going to be equal to 18 times the square
root of 7 so just
like that you saw it only took a couple
of minutes to apply Heron's formula or
even less than that to figure out that
the area of this triangle right here the
area is equal to 18 square roots of 7
anyway hopefully found that pretty neat